to our honorable and faithful leaders I
want to say thank you
thank you for your kindness generosity
of spirit and your concern for our
future at first we rejected you but that
was because we did not understand we
didn't realize how much he needed you we
didn't appreciate that your arrival was
precious gift
the presence has rouses from our
couple's
complacency
we have awoken from our wasteful sleep
and taking responsibility for our future
we have renewed pride in our work
we are once again
enterprising
resourceful
and cooperative
thanks to you
and you have rediscovered who we are and
there's no turning back to our apathetic
and miss bellies
a new day has dawned and a brighter
future beckons and for this
hi I'm CJ senior narrative designer at
dam Buster studios in homefront the
revolution we've taken an incredible
premise a fallen America occupied by a
foreign power and built an open-world
shooter that puts the player in the role
of a guerilla soldier fighting for
freedom we're gonna show you a brief
glimpse of guerrilla warfare Homefront
style from our single-player experience
which is playable here at Gamescom
but for homefront the revolution will
also offer a compelling cooperative
multiplayer mode in which you and your
friends can form a resistance cell and
become heroes of the revolution we're
gonna be working Microsoft to test it
out and we're proud to announce today
that Xbox one owners will enjoy
exclusive early access to the homefront
multiplayer beta this winter thanks just
need the target will get you those
locations as soon as we can reach the
KPA transceiver will download the data
ok I said get up to that intersection
make sure it's clear
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]